six people have been killed and another
injured at a kindergarten in China the
attack took place in Guangdong Province
north of Hong Kong a 25 year old suspect
has been taken into police custody for
questioning we're going to bring in our
China correspondent Katrina you now
she's joining us live from Beijing uh
what more do we know about this attack
Katrina
well Guangdong police have released a
report saying that it took place Monday
morning local time about 8 A.M in Liang
County in Guangdong in a place called
town that six people were killed and one
person was injured and they've
implicated a 25 year old man named Wu
and that he is currently detained and
they've said that investigations are
ongoing now in addition to that we don't
have any firm details yet but this
shocking attack the shocking nature of
it has taken hold of social media here
in China and there's lots of information
going around screenshots that are said
to be being shared by locals in that
particular Town local media have picked
up these social media accounts and
provided a few more details saying that
this attack involved a stabbing that
children are among the dead and they say
that according to screenshots shared
from WeChat discussion group that this
all started because of dispute between
parents where one child it was
apparently harmed by a car now I have to
say that this is all unverified
information so far we have to wait for
further details from the authorities but
this already has started a lot of
discussion about the level of security
around schools although this kind of
violent crime is not common in China due
to strict uh Crime and Punishment laws
death penalty is often the consequence
for those suspected of murder
it is also a sparkling discussion about
security and also the nature of the
judicial system given its opaqueness
experts have attributed this kind of
horrendous Revenge attacks to to the the
level of uh untransparency lack of
transparency in the judicial system so
it's awful often down to people who are
unwell or desperate or impassioned
unfortunately all right Katrina thank
you for that that is Katrina you with
what we know so far about this attack in
Guangdong thank you